Welcome to Google
Developers Hackademy.
This is the first part
of the Android SDK
introduction course,
developed by Enrique Diaz,
from GDG Androidtitlan Mexico.
If this is your first contact
with the course,
I recommend you watch it
in order and do the exercises.
Welcome to lesson 3:
"Building blocks for Android."
My name is Enrique Diaz
and remember
that last time we saw
basic tools for developing
in Eclipse IDE.
In this lesson we will see
three very important things
for developing.
We will learn what's an activity,
we will implement a fragment,
and finally, we will learn
how to start an intent.
Next, we will talk about
what's an activity.
An activity is a class contained
in Android framework
to create use interfaces.
Imagine, like in a browser
we have windows,
it's equivalent in Android
is an activity.
I already have a project here
called Hola Mundo,
in which we will implement
an activity.
So we enter MainActivity
and will go quickly over
which methods are implemented.
They are two:
onCreate and
onCreateOptionsMenu.
In order to create an activity,
with a right click,
we hit "New"
and then we look for "Class,"
and, when we select it,
it creates a window
where we need to add a name
and a superclass.
In this case we will name it
"OtherActivity"
and we will inherit
from Activity.
Having this we hit on "Finish"
and, in our package
mx.androidtitlan.holamundo,
we already have
this class created
just as we did it.
Now we will override
a method
in order to add onCreate.
We hit "OK"
and automatically
it generates this codelines.
I format a bit
and now I'm writing
the setContentView method,
which receives a parameter,
which is the layout
of my activity.
We can see it on this side,
where we have our files,
in the layout folder.
We will also create
an .xml file in there
right-clicking
on my layout folder,
I hit "New..."
and then "Android XML file."
There, it will allow me to add
a name for my file.
This one I will name
activity_other.xml.
And while I'm at it,
I can see
which elements I can have
as parent of my file.
We have ScrollView,
SlidingDrawer,
Space, Spinner,
TextView, etcetera, etcetera.
In this case I look for
RelativeLayout,
which is the layout
that allows us to add views
and define them
depending on others.
When I open my file,
I can notice it has nothing,
just the title inside my file,
but I can also see
its parent tag,
which is just RelativeLayout.
We will add the first activity
in the first TextView.
In the second TextView
we will just place
a TextView, we format it,
we take the chance to visualize
some properties
of RelativeLayout,
like aligning to the parent
at the top,
wide, tall, margin.
And if we go to
the graphical interface,
we can notice the change.
I'm going to close this file.
And inside the method
setContentView
of OtherActivity
I'm going to pass it
this other .xml file
and, as with any activity,
I have to declare it
inside AndroidManifest.
In this case,
in HolaMundoManifest
I have to copy
the activity tags.
And now I'm going to run
my example.
For that, see the play button
of the upper menu?
I click on it and then,
in that window that shows up,
I hit Android Application.
So I select it and I'll wait
for the emulator
to launch the application.
Before it's launched,
a window will show up
where it allows me to choose
if I want to launch
the application in a device
that is already ready,
connected to the framework,
or if I want to launch
a new virtual device.
In this case, I will use one
that is already connected.
One interesting thing
about this window
is that it tells you to select
a device with the minimum API
your project is configured with.
In this case, it's API level 8.
I select
genymotion-galaxy_nexus,
I hit "OK,"
and that's it!
We can already see
my app Hola Mundo
with two texts that we created.
"Mi primer Activity"
and "TextView."
Up next we will see
the concept of intent.
An intent is a class
within the framework
that allows us to relate
one activity with another.
Whether we know it or not.
That, precisely,
is the concept of explicit
or implicit intent.
Okay...
Now, the same instance
of Hola Mundo.
Let's create an intent.
For that, I'll go to
OtherActivity.java
and I will modify the .xml file
called "Activity_other.xml."
I'm going to drag a button
from the user interface,
and I'll add another one
below it.
I'll name the first one
"Open browser,"
and the second one,
in the "text" property,
will be
"Enter another activity."
Besides, I will add
the onClick property,
which will receive a method
for both buttons.
The first one will be
"openBrowser,"
and the second one, the method
will be "openActivity."
The onClick property,
in a view, like a button,
allows us to send to it
a method as a parameter
which, in Java coding,
will do something.
This is the easiest way
of making
a listener of a button.
Now, in my
OtherActivity.java class,
I'm going to build both methods.
For that, I have to write this:
"public void method"
and I pass it a parameter,
which is the view
that will be called.
Inside the method
I'm going to declare
an intent-like object.
This one will be called
"openBrowser."
Inside openBrowser method,
which receives
the "view" parameter,
where "view" is the button
to which we're sending
or defining the method,
we're going to create
an intent instance,
which receives two parameters:
intent.ACTION_VIEW,
and the URL which I want
to access.
Besides, I have to initialize
the activity
with the startActivity method,
and which receives the intent
as a parameter.
Then, I will create another
method called "openActivity."
It will also receive a View
as a parameter.
Besides, I will create
an intent instance.
The difference is it'll receive
two different parameters.
In this second intent,
it will receive the context
of the package and of the class.
In this case is one
of the parameters,
otherActivity.this,
and the second parameter
is where I want to go.
Said in a simpler way,
de second parameter
of the intent it receives
is where I am,
and where I want to access.
And I also initialize
the activity
with the method startActivity
and I pass the intent to it,
as a parameter.
I'm going to run the app.
the same dialogue shows up.
Done, I now have both buttons
inside my activity.
What each button should do
is, the first button,
ask me
"What do you want to open?,"
because, in the particular case
of my emulator,
I have two applications
that open URIs,
which is the URL
I'm passing to it.
Here we proved
an implicit un intent.
I can select
any of the two options,
I can select it does it
every time it's opened
or just once.
And when I click on it,
it automatically opens
the browser and it will enter
the URL I sent to it
inside the intent,
which in this case is
androidtitlan.mx.
Back to the example,
and with the other button,
all it does is send me
to the other activity.
Why? this other intent
is an explicit intent,
because what I'm defining
is where I am
and where I want to go.
Now we will se how to implement
a fragment.
A fragment is an user interface
that's not a view
or an activity.
It's rather a subactivity,
in some way.
It allows us to insert,
in a programmatic way,
or through an XML,
any element
we want to reuse in our code.
In this example,
which will be a totally new one,
we enter the package
mx.androidtitlan.xmlfragment.
In the class MainActivity.java,
the first thing we have to do
is change the class
from which it inherits
and we will modify it
through fragmentActivity.
We will leave as it is,
but we will create
a new fragment,
a Java class that will be
called Simplefragment,
that will inherit from Fragment.
In my Simplefragment.java,
what I will return
in onCreateView
is the LayoutInflater,
which is the one in charge
of inflating views, layouts,
inflater.inlfate,
and I'll pass it the interface
that I want to inflate.
Inside my fragment
I contain a TextView.
I'm going to change the text
for "fragment" only
and I'll add a background
to the parent view,
any color,
in this case, "f123."
I use the "f" to define,
whether the parameter,
or I use it to define
if it'll have a transparency.
When you put "f"
in hexadecimals
that have no transparency,
and "123" is
a hexadecimal as it is.
And I'll also modify
the activity_main file,
which is the interface
of my activity.
What I'm going to do is enter
the graphical interface,
and I drag
the "fragment" component.
So, as you can see,
it's shown on the display,
and I'll modify some things.
I'll modify the width
and the height,
just to have control and to know
where's my fragment,
that is being called
from an .xml file.
Now I run the application
and there it is,
I can see a "Hello world,"
which contains the activity,
but also, I see a square
the size of my fragment.
This means that what I did was,
through the .xml file,
show a fragment
inside an activity,
insert it.
Now, let's do another example
but inserting the fragment
programmatically.
This means it will be
through Java code.
For that, the same way,
I'm going to build a fragment
that will be named as:
"SimpleFragment,"
and that will also inherit
from Fragment.
Careful, it's very important
that it inherits from
android.support.v4,
because that way we can use
this compatibility backwards
and we can develop apps
from API level 4.
I select it, hit "Finish,"
and I wait for it to visualize
in my package.
I also implement a method
that is also onCreateView.
What I will return
in the method onCreateView
will be inflater.inflate
and now I will pass it
three parameters,
which are what's the interface
I want to be shown,
the container, which is
the activity to which
it is being added,
and a Boolean parameter,
which is false.
Besides, I'll take the chance
to create another .xml file
that will be called
fragment_main.
To this one I'll pass,
inside the parent view,
which is the RelativeLayout,
a parameter,
which is background,
with a "f123" numeral.
What this means is that
I'm passing it a color
where my first digit
is the transparency,
and the other three
are a hexadecimal number.
Besides, inside the text
contained in this fragment,
I'll write "fragment" only.
Now, the parameter I need
in the interface
of the main activity is the ID.
So I declare it:
android:id
and I use "@+id"
because that way I tell
my class R
that I want to add an instance,
which I want to access.
I close that file
and now I'm going to declare,
inside the .xml file,
how I am going to call
my fragment.
I'll do it right below
setContentView,
but besides, don't forget
to change the superclass.
In this case it will be
"FragmentActivity."
It will inherit MainActivity
from FragmentActivity.
To be able to call
getSupportFragmentManager
.beginTransaction.add,
to which I will pass
two parameters.
What's the ID to which
I want to add
within my interface?
I mean, I am using
ID container
that I added
inside my RelativeLayout,
that I just modified,
and I show it
what I want to add.
In this case,
I just wrote a line above
where I am defining
a SimpleFragment instance,
which is SimpleFragment,
that is called
fragment = new SimpleFragment.
I launch my application...
and that's it, I can see that,
in a programmatic way,
I'm calling a fragment
that is being executed
or inserted
inside my activity.
Let's recapitulate.
In this lesson we saw
three important points:
we created and understood
what is an activity,
we implemented an intent,
and, finally, we knew
the power of a fragment.
Remember, next lesson
we will see
a real life example
creating my own Android app.
My name is Enrique Diaz.
Keep on programming!